most calls are routine every once in a
while you get that call we're all hell's
breaking loose and to most people it
looks like a blazing monster but I
understand how it behaves how it
progresses I said the same thing every
time I say trust me do everything that I
asked and I promise you'll stay alive
today
you see the man you saw at the store say
his number still before you step forward
and repeat the phrase Jerry Thomas
biggie is a sociopath but if he is a
stone-cold killer Jeremy we can't get
Haven unless you testify
so what whole life just goes away I will
put you in witness protection
breathe line up your target and squeeze
your new identity is already being
arranged been erased you're a ghost but
you'll be safe what the hell do you
think you're doing
we're u.s. marshals not amateurs ever
see some
one day so we'll fight you
I'm a ghost I don't exist the hell with
this petition you're gonna need petition
from me I have a Ruger security six 357
mag
he's never gonna stop
the man's gone his dark side